meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
die zuschauer von euch die main kanal
schnellsten folgen wissen dass ich eine
besondere beziehung zu youtube erst hab
die ganze sache ging damals damit einem
video den sie einfach vier oder fünf
produktion gemacht hat und ich mich
einfach ich musste mich einfach darüber
lustig machen soll wie youtube 2016
leute wir sind bei sieben minuten und 4
sekunden und wir haben in diesem video
vier placement und danach folgte eine
große anfrage videos auf einem kanal in
dem ich manchmal kritische dinge über
sie gesagt hab manchmal nette dinge
okay nicht so viele nette dinge darauf
gab es relativ lange funkstille ich habe
auch keine videos mehr züge gemacht aber
jetzt ist die zeit gekommen wieder eins
zu machen und zwar geht es darum dass
diesem kind bekommen hat was eine
riesige sache ist ein sehr schöne sachen
wahrscheinlich mit zu den größten events
oder meilenstein im leben zieht die man
überhaupt haben kann und es geht darum
was das internet dazu sagt willi hat
dieses bild gepostet unser cash ist am
übrigens auch mein geburtstag an sich
war am gleichen tag geburtstag wie babys
kind hallo liebes kind das hier so
jedenfalls inspiriert darüber wie schön
das für sie ist so ein kind zu haben und
das alles andere steht in dem moment und
dann gibt es eben kommentare dazu sehr
schön was bekommt das kind eine eigene
instagram account damit ist als
influencer geld verdienen und ihr es
euch in die taschen stecken könnte das
ist so eine sache die gar nicht
verstehen dass es so ein emotionaler
moment kann man in dem moment nicht
einfach kurz die klappe also ich bin der
allererste das bedeutet lustig machen
irgendwas passt oder so aber dann
vielleicht nicht ich war wo soll es
hingehen wenn dann irgendwann mal der
vater von dem influenza stirbt also mein
vater ist nicht mehr unter uns und dann
so topp kommentar wurde von den toten
er verliebt ist der name monte also bis
moment ein insider hat promiflash den
wir verraten dass sie wieder in ihrem
sohn den ausgefallenen namen monti amos
gegeben haben sollen
ein anderer hobby detektiv wird so
überaus gewarnt haben das im oktober in
einem kölner krankenhaus tatsächlich
erkennt genannte oslos bruder gut dann
heißt seit montag gilt ja nichts an wie
andere leute ihr kind nein oder ja ich
bin professioneller experte führender
umgebung von kindern hauptsächlich
unterwegs sind instagram kommentaren und
ich sehe sie wollen ihr kind lisa lernen
was soll die scheiße mann das ding muss
alle kritischen sie missbrauchen ihr
kind für den medienhype es sollte ein
gesetz geben das es verbietet fotos von
kindern unter 14 jahren hochzuladen da
sie nicht gefragt werden können
beziehungsweise sie die folgen davon
verstehen finde ich super man sollte das
generell verbieten das glückliche eltern
bilder von ihren kindern draußen wo
kommen wir denn da hin wenn das eigene
kind auf die welt gekommen ist ganz
ehrlich behaltet die scheiße bitte für
euch so caspar gib mir mal sein ganzes
kindergeld ab ja ich will eine [ __ ]
aber niemand wird es herausfinden weil
wieder zu viele kommentare geschrieben
werden
von einem punkt [ __ ] katar kasse
witcher 2 count kleine rote misst sie
hat die geburt überlebt
darüber kann nicht mal ein witz machen
das ist einfach so ein [ __ ]
kommentar welten.de am ende ist es doch
fruchtzwerge bietet sie die rastet aus
hochzeitsflug mein kind soll
fruchtzwerge
angeblich so redet keine mein kind
landliebe j15 das kind bringt wieder ein
paar das das symbol für jena und vorne
das kind bringt wieder ein paar euro
aber wen interessiert schon das wohl des
kindes
ganz ehrlich das fühlt sich so selbst
aber an weil ich bin in einem video auf
seinem kanal sks verteidigen wie aber
ist kommentare so dumm die checks du
irgendwas im leben die frau hat etliche
millionen euro auf dem konto und vika
gibt wieso bringt ein kind zu haben geld
kindergeld oder wie kindergärten also
bei allen geräten aller kritik muss man
einfach wissen wie sie ist steinreich
ihr habt mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit
ausgesagt ihr ganzes leben und hat
deswegen auch ihr kind nicht bekommen um
geld zu verdienen sein wahrscheinlich
einfach bock hat auf dem kind und das
schön verletzt ach ja dann noch auch
ganz wichtig zum abschluss noch nicht zu
vergessen auf gar keinen fall zu
vernachlässigen der kommentar von arzt
in deutschland wer auf dieser erde steht
kommt vorbei und der papiertonne geburt
vor dem trend alter macht mir zu leben